good morning with john langler heather
mills at the anchor desk and bianca
holmen watching traffic nathan taliban
with the weather and it is raining in
parts of town even as we speak but not
all over town the official temperature
at 73 humidity is not that bad and
neither is the dew point wind is light
we're going to get some gusty wind
around these storms so let's jump right
into the radar over the last several
hours and to right now it looks like
mountains edge picking up some lightning
and thunder great email thank you so
much for writing in about thunder booms
over desert inn and town center also
thanks for the video from southern
highlands we appreciate you letting us
know that you've got rain where you are
and you can send us your pictures and
video to pix
8newsnow.com so the west and the
southwest picking up some rain right now
so be very careful on your commute we're
going to see waves of this off and on
throughout the day today so over the
next hour or two it's going to slack off
and then come back again neighborhood
temperatures in the upper 60s to the low
70s in the meantime around the rest of
the region we got low 40s up in ely and
chances rain all over so let's talk
about the commute and see if there are
any problems related to the weather or
elsewhere here's bianca